[Music]
initially
people thought that disability is a
curse but i have changed the
perception of the community
and now they're accepting that
examinations
are our only few challenge work instead
i know i work differently so i do my
things differently
but i am a person like any other person
my dad used to tell me to do farming but
i was not interested i thought it was
very dirty
that's why i did i.t so i wanted to do
anything to do technology and computers
behind the desktop and studying other
things
now my it background assists me a lot
because i learn
online i market my produce
technology has come to change what my
dad used to do
and i can change family water whatever
i'm doing here i can sell it online
instead of now taking my vegetables to
the market
they are collected from home you get
your money quietly
with no disturbance and
you can go somewhere with a girl the
purpose you know that's why you find me
having these pigs
feeding them like my babies you know you
must love
whatever you do once you change the
mindset and
and you know you love whatever you're
doing you achieve a lot
young people believe that naropa is the
only place where you can
make money or you can get employed i
take advantage of being next to nairobi
because
most people in nairobi feed from here
that was also another reason why i
tended to do family
for the youth now they should also know
that
ugly business is also an employment if
you exist where we're in agribusiness
you can get as much as you would wish to
get
so you should come over and join me
during farming
[Music]